Savannah pump rolls oh lordy this is I
need a drink yes off to fight the most
running out of the gate season we've had
I know
trust me I'm produced on that show and
when I saw episode 2 I'm thinking like
this should be the finale it's so
explosive it's like how do we get there
so quickly don't tell me the troops you
did have sex with her
yes that's true yes rotten hill when you
found out Jax had cheated on Brittany
what was your reaction look Jax is a
great guy in so many respects and it's a
lot of fun however he doesn't understand
that life's not all about him if you're
in a relationships about your partner's
feelings I think that's one thing we
want to see what do you make of Brittany
standing by him now well you're gonna
see how this plays out it's not like a
straight line there are a lot of women
that put up with a lot of things that
maybe some other women wouldn't write
and I think we don't know really what
the benefits are that they're
experiencing it might supersede the
downfall so to speak we need to strip
and make it and see what's really going
on down there because something is
keeping a clue there I did something
really stupid today
I don't know it was just like a moment
of weakness
we
today I know I shouldn't have done that
of that group yes
who has surprised you the most over the
years and who are you just like get it
together who surprised me the most I
think I always knew Stassi had great
potential she's smart she really is
she's smart as a whip that girl but you
know they both surprised me and
disappointed me what's been your biggest
disappointment over the course of that
show I think I seen this season maybe
something was Schwartz eat it I wasn't
happy with okay and I put a lot in best
finish Schwartz seeing a lot investing
JP so any time even put a foot wrong
that would not make me happy okay I
don't like that you probably would this
is not good this is bad
ba ba I have no recollection of this but
it doesn't mean anything other is that
what's going to surprise us the most
outside of the Jax for anything whatever
goes so quickly I mean it's a plethora
of convoluted you know I mean this
recent we have 24 episode we could
actually have 44
[Music]